i i dislike these guys so much i can't
even i get mad at even thinking about
why
why do you get mad thinking about these
guys
patrick
they've identified in the city of la 17
gangs
that are following people to their homes
they're they're they're tracking them in
restaurants and this isn't the these are
gangs that could be indicted under the
rico statue because they're criminal
enterprises they're very sophisticated
they're tracking people from their
restaurant to their home
and and robbing them at gunpoint at
their home they've identified 17 gangs
the lapd now has a unit just for this
gang violence
you can go into stores rite aid stores
and and other pharmacies that are
closing left and right in all of
california because now shoplifting is a
misdemeanor for anything under a
thousand dollars people are going in
there writing broad daylight on camera
don't care and taking 950 worth of
merchandise off the shelf and walking
out of the store and nothing happens to
them
i mean people are not going to tolerate
this normal working people blue they're
not going to tolerate this doesn't
matter democrat republican or whatever
but this is what's this is what is going
on now i'll ask you a question what is
the reasoning behind this
now of course we're hearing that soros
is putting all of these people in he's
backing their campaigns he's getting
them in office but even there what's
what's the reasoning behind it i i don't
understand it why do you want criminals
to be pampered so they can go out and
commit more crimes and you want you know
regular citizens to be the victims and
do nothing about it what's the mentality
behind this
you know i consider myself fairly astute
i can't figure this out i don't know
what the plan is
is it somebody that's really looking to
destroy america from within
you know is that what's really happening
in these major cities
i i don't i don't know but why would you
do that though because
even the guy sometimes even the guy
that's going through it that he's
relying on everybody else but you know
hey i'll give you this for free i'll
give you that for free
even if they bring the whole empire down
they get crushed because they're not the
creators and the initiators
they rely on the creator and the
initiator you know but maybe they're
oblivious to it maybe it's an ego thing
maybe it's
you know
if you rarely earn anything in life you
really don't care whether anything you
lose anything you never build it in the
first place to have any kind of
uh uh
responsibility or pain of loss
uh who knows what the motive is with
that but you know sometimes you gotta
sometimes certain states you know
jedediah on her podcast
that got started last week on the first
episode she just flat out said listen if
you're living in these cities and states
leave i have to tell you this just leave
i lived in new york she's saying this i
was in new york i left if you're living
in california leave if you're living in
chicago illinois leave why are you
staying there they have to feel the pain
that you're leaving too many people are
sitting there saying oh
no i'm just going to stay here because
of this and because of that no listen
i'm leaving here's what i'm doing i'm
going to a different state that's her
position where maybe eventually it needs
to get to a point where they're gonna
sit around and say
uh guys we're losing way too many people
just yesterday you know they're having
this conversation with um msnbc is
having a conversation with uh one of
their uh guests that's sitting there
saying well it's not that bad gas prices
are not this is the putin putin uh gas
hike did you see that which which story
is that by the way the it's in the
middle of page two with uh you're
talking about uh
nbc host willie geist yeah willie geist
yeah nbc willie geist he says i want to
read this to you he says uh
uh nbc host tells biden official that
americans see right through the his
putin price hike spin okay this is msnbc
saying this you can't lose msnbc maybe
you lose a little bit of jake tapper
from cnn fine but you cannot lose msnbc
willie geist told the director of white
house national economic council
friday that americans are not blaming
russia president vladimir putin for
soaring gas prices brian it's true of
course that russia's war in ukraine has
impacted oil prices yes but i promise
you the landscaper two days ago i talked
to about gas pump who was trying to fill
up two cans uh and backpack blowers and
mowers in his truck was not going damn
you putin so what do you say to him what
do you say to families who can't afford
all these groceries
right now the nac director brian rose uh
brian dee said these gas prices uh which
exceed five dollars per gallon uh
thursday is hitting families hard then
he said gas prices have increased a
dollar seventy since putin amassed
troops at the ukraine border i think
eventually these arguments get exposed
even yesterday or not yesterday three
days ago when
bill maher had kellyanne conway on
and who's the other person that he on he
had he had a few different people on and
he said look guys
if kavanaugh is getting a death threat
and new york times doesn't cover it the
next day if that was a democratic
supreme court no it would be right it
would be a cover story he says this is
the hypocrisy of new york times where
people don't trust and it's not coming
from tucker carlson that's coming from
bill maher
you can't lose these people that you've
had for decades and that's what's
starting to happen to many of them i got
to tell you this i was never a fan of
bill maher's mainly because i didn't
like the way he treated christians and
you know and he was religiously
religious
you know yeah religious yeah but um and
also because i thought he was really far
left
but as you're watching him now i have a
different opinion of him i mean i like
him more now because he's calling it as
he sees it and listen
i mean he said it right out with the new
york times but you know it's it's a
deeper issue
this was a supreme court judge that
somebody went up to his house and was
saying they were going to assassinate
him and here we are with mainstream
media and not even wanting to cover it
i mean
what are they thinking
i mean this is
patrick this is worse than street stuff
i'm telling you i mean these people say
it's okay to kill a supreme court judge
they don't want to cover it they want
they want people to know that
i mean how do you start that what kind
of mentality is going on in this country
and that's why i'm saying this has
become more mob like even the press even
the media to cover things up like this i
mean this is serious stuff yeah they
would talk about how schumer
uh you remember when schumer said hey
absolutely he'll pay the price for row
resurfaces and he said it passionately
and some are saying wait a minute that's
a threat you know and he says you know
uh uh i want to tell you you know i want
to tell you kavanaugh you have released
the whirlwind and you will pay the price
you won't know what hits you if you go
forward with these awful decisions right
and then he has to come back this is
schumer's word now some people may say
well that sounds like what happened at
the january 6 when trump said this
entire
so the point becomes this then the view
i don't know if you saw the view or not
you don't seem like the type of person
that watches the view religiously
although it's a it's a very good show to
watch if you like to increase your blood
pressure it's a very good show to watch
but you see them saying well well yeah
and then but
yeah but you see what he's saying you
see what mcconnell said you see what
they said no here's what's going on
hypocrisy at its best
all across the board and it's being
revealed fyi it's both the left and
right and if you try to impose hypocrisy
it's eventually going to be
losing like guns right now the debate
that they're having with guns right now
where
you know 10 senators from outside
they're sitting there saying hey so
here's what we propose because i don't
know if you saw matthew mcconaughey's
speech that did you actually watch
so i watch the speech and i'm sitting
there this is a guy i'm a second
amendment guy
i have multiple m16s i have shotguns i
have guns i'm all for it i think i want
everybody to be trained but you're
sitting there listening to this guy
saying okay
uh yeah i wouldn't mind more people
being trained i can see why the age may
increase from 18 to 21. i can see that
okay fine background check fine when i
was in dallas
i went to the local gun shop i bought an
m16 with a magazine and full of rounds
and it took me i bought it i went walked
into the store at 11 41
by 11 59 i left with everything
bought it walked out nothing
i'm a safe guy to buy that stuff and
then i made a video about it to document
it but
should the average guy be able to do
that should the average guy be able to
do that if he's taking medication some
people are making these proposals why
don't we look at them right
but the same thing goes also with nra
you know they also don't want anybody to
make any changes to talk about anything
i think what's happening today is the
following
row v wade hey here's what's going to
take place i can't believe you're doing
this
guns this is what's i can't believe
you're doing this but the american
people are saying
look
this sounds reasonable this sounds
reasonable the unreasonable folks you're
so loud you're convincing the reasonable
people that you have a point and you
don't so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]